alors jean n'a rien rien moi c'est mon
nom moment d'aider ces mamans
ah bon tu m'entends bon oui on n'est pas
sale et ouais t'as un crayon bon alors
pilote bas on habite du nid 3 unis bah
comme ça s'écrit 122-100 bâti de
boulevard de la source
lotissement 16 bâtiments à risque liés b
rightsflow ses portes 1094 ouais ça fait
du monde à l'orage on rentre on a une
grosse et alors tu la connais ma maurice
et laurent m6 lé point de la même
religion que la nôtre alors elle m'a
donné la barre ali baraka bave un ouais
c'était bien contente d'aider aussi mais
demande quand même elle vous est ce que
ça me lire parce que des des moindres on
sait pas alors louisette à laver laisse
pas les dernières elle doit connaître
merci on est très très bien la maison
j'ai par le visage si on se croirait
presque à la cantine genre dans
l'hexagone
1 c'est rien n'en sais rien c'est le
passage
ouais mais j'ai oublié de dire du mal de
la cuisine du bois non et ben moi je
vois les avions atterrir sur la piste
juste à côté de nous ouais mais ça
change un peu de sa brawn mais on peut
pas passer toute sa vie à sa brawn a vu
ce poète oublie parce que de l'autre
côté j'ai quand même la chance d'avoir
le périphérique juste en dessous alors
tu penses avec les éclairages de la
route
on voit très bien comme ça pas besoin
d'allumer la lumière
quelle économie même le match je sais
que dd se lève tous les matins à 5
heures 30
pourquoi 32 à 6 heures du bas coûts
directs
le premier vol de lutter quoi maintenant
ah non je connais pas non ces magazines
du 14e jean deschamps sont très gentils
avec très forte ce que j'écoute une
gentille et je le vois pas pourquoi qui
nous ferait lagalaye ah bah oui d'aider
aussi entrer plus qui manque le père de
paris la boîte
partout elle il a les pieds tout reflux
forcément on est seront faits par le sol
sinon je vais te faire une surprise
dimanche prochain c'est à l'émission de
radio à 532 le temps va venise et
bretagne par tino rossi
c'est un rappel rabab des quotas soto
rate pas je pense très bien la toile en
même temps que le bal un coup direct
c'est la même heure et ben voilà la
petite mort voilà toutes les nouvelles
tombera très bon ouais non c'est pas
n'avions fait dédé qui va me rendre là
encore tout le salon ben écoute tu
embrasses bien aux lettres la malène
bourgeois qui m'a dit je vais te dire
j'ai j'ai acheté trois bouts la teinture
aux pour la robe de l'os en coupant les
manches et bah je pense pouvoir la
ressortir pour l'arbre de grêle notre
prochaine sortie à la mutualité
mais j'espère qu'elle va bien prendre
malgré les tâches ou de brands hatch
bon ben ali dont je raccroche pas ce que
ça va te coûter le forcing tout ça voilà
tout va bien je t'embrasse tout va bien
tout va bien
bonnaire